[Musique]
2018 c'est l'année de la refondation
2018 ça va être un nouveau souffle pour
les républicains c'est l'année où on va
enfin pouvoir réussir à reconstruire
notre parti on a un nouveau président on
a une nouvelle équipe jeune qui est très
dynamique solidaire qui rassemble
plusieurs sensibilités politiques qui
est convaincu je suis content de voir
que dans notre majorité politique ait
encore des gens de conviction qu'ils
sont capables de porter nos valeurs
à droite de 2018 c'est celle qui va
enfin pouvoir réussir à faire s'exprimer
toutes les idées et toutes les
thématiques on a sur le coeur
toutes les sensibilités politiques de la
droite peuvent se rassembler partager
débattre et c'est ça le plus important
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui fait notre
force justement ces débats internes qui
permettent un est reparti de trouver les
meilleurs projets la droite aujourd'hui
c'est un mouvement qui se veut ouvert
qui se veut large qui va pouvoir réussir
à parler à l'ensemble des français c'est
le seul parti politique qui représente
toute la france dans sa diversité qui
s'intéresse à toutes les classes y
compris les classes moyennes qui sont de
plus en plus délaissé aujourd'hui la
droite elle est fière elle est fière de
ses valeurs
elle est courageuse la doite aujourd'hui
c'est une droite qui conserve sa valeur
mais qui est également tournée vers
l'avenir et vers le progrès une droite
clair qu'il ne s'excuse pas une droite
qui n'a pas peur d'être de droite qui
valorisait le mérite qui valorise l
excellence et je pense que les
républicains on a tous on commence cette
valeur de travail
la valeur mérite la valeur travail voilà
la fiscalité de demain aussi pour les
entreprises pour les particuliers le
respect de l'autre l'école l'éducation
la sécurité l'immigration la droite que
nous voulons elle n'a pas peur de parler
d'identité le sans pour autant
stigmatiser de se battre et d'être en
opposition par rapport bien sûr à la csg
et elle parlera certainement parce que
je leur fais confiance d'une cause qui
est important pour moi le handicap
laurent wauquiez a beaucoup parlé
[Applaudissements]
la france a besoin des républicains la
france d'aujourd'hui a besoin des
républicains nous devons aimer ce pays
et nous devons nous engager ça va être
très important dans les années à venir
il faut que nous soyons là est vraiment
de plus en plus fort
[Musique]